a six-year-old boy in Texas is finding
his voice for the first time after a
simple procedure helped him start
talking
Mason Matz's parents thought their child
was a bit tongue-tied because of a
developmental disorder but they didn't
know that being tongue-tied is a real
and treatable condition until a
life-changing trip to the dentist
Omar Villafranca met Mason and his
parents in Texas was this kind of
communication even possible no this
wasn't this was not our life
Mason mots doesn't care that grown-ups
are talking
that's you because now he's the one with
something to say his parents Meredith
and Allen mots ate last year the
six-year-old could barely speak the
beginning of words not the end of words
really poor enunciation the Texas family
chalked up Mason's speech problems to a
brain aneurysm discovered when he was 10
days old and to a developmental disorder
but early last year their lives changed
when they went to kids town dental in
Katy Texas while working on some
cavities dr. Amy glutamine Lazar noticed
that Mason was tongue-tied and he see
how close it is to the tip she saw the
band of tissue under his tongue was
connected much closer to the tip than
normal which makes it harder to talk she
asked to the parents if she could do a
simple procedure and use a laser to cut
the tissue no cross bites no crowding
how long did it take for you to do that
procedure with the laser understand
maybe 30 seconds that quick yeah and the
results are life-changing studies have
found the condition is prevalent for
between four and ten percent of infants
and for Mason the small fix made a big
difference how quick did you start
noticing things that evening what was
one thing that you noticed immediately
after the procedure instead of pointing
to food or pointing to his mouth he was
able to say mom I'm hungry I said Dallas
darling get over here like Mason would
you say I'm trying to get him to say it
again
just like what do you do at school today
I miss doing science the matzo say Mason
it's catching up verbally and they are
grateful that their miracle worker to be
their dentist this wasn't on our path
our path was we need to get his teeth
better when you see a case like Mason's
what does that do for you professionally
all right is why I come to work every
day for CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca Katy Texas Thank You
dr. Amy Ludum and Lazar who I don't know
it's something in 30 seconds
Wow there's just a reminder sometimes a
doctor you know just getting a couple of
different opinions can really help you
six years old they're very chatty smell
but they'll but they'll but they never
get tired of hearing him talk right he's
gonna catch up quick some days your kids
are dying you go okay that's enough that
you'll never gets sick of hearing the
sound of his voice